I was in an interview with a female journalist some years back
who told me that the, the trans issue was a complicated one.
I think that's why she put it,
a lot of people differ on that subject.
And I said, well,
who differs on it? I don't.
I don't understand anybody who would
can't grasp the concept that they're human beings
and they deserve the rights that the rest of us have.
The LGBT has got a T in there for a reason.
They started our movement.
They. And it's not the time to desert them
and count out to some primitive way of thinking.
People have a right to live their lives in this free culture.
And if that means living a life as a trans person,
because that's what makes sense to them,
it doesn't matter that it doesn't make sense to you,
it makes sense to them and it's their right to live that out.
And what. And what about the question of what their rights are,
you know, when they come to be defined in law
and changing rooms and sports categories and all of that?
It always comes down to the bathroom, toilets, toilets.
It always does.
When any, ever anybody's wants to attack the rights of queers,
it comes down to toilets.
Leave them alone. Just leave us alone.
I say us because I include myself with my trans brothers and sisters.
We're in this battle together and I won't consider myself You know,
placidly queer until that happens